noch immer ist er nicht gefunden aber
gibt es ein wissenschaftlich von jede
vermutung wie er aussehen könnte der
geheimnisvolle neunte planet in unserem
sonnensystem da müsste das auch deutlich
ein fahrrad wie aufzuspüren wobei so
einfach dann auch nicht wie es gelingen
könnte und was wir über den neunten
planeten wissen jetzt endlich zum
science fiction herzlich willkommen
bei der letzten jahre sind sich die
astrophysiker ziemlich sicher irgendwo
da draußen gibt es einen neuen planeten
ohne ihn wären zahlreiche umlaufbahn von
objekten im kupfergürtel unseres
sonnensystems nicht erklärbar erst ein
neunter planet der zehn mal massereicher
und deutlich größer als die erde ist
kann diese baden erklären mike brown und
konstantin battleship vom california
institute of technology hatten damals
die beiden sehr genau untersucht die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass die bahn diese
objekte alle um 30 grad von der
bahnebene der restlichen planeten
abweiche dass sie zufällig sei lag
demnach bei 0 7 prozent das ist also
nahezu ausgeschlossen dass erneute
planet nicht existiert aber wie spürt
man hinauf der neunten planeten und 20
mal weiter weg als der äußerste planet
neptun und braucht etwa 10 bis 20
tausend jahre für eine umrundung der
sonne
es sieht also moment eher schlecht aus
ihn schnell zu finden wenn man aber
wüsste wie er aussieht könnte es viel
leichter sein ihn zu lokalisieren wäre
wirklich sensationell wissenschaftler
wissenschaftlerin von der universität
bern haben jetzt erforscht wie ein
planet 9 aussehen könnte esther linda
und christoph marzini haben dafür
simuliert wie sich unser sonnensystem
mit neunten planeten entwickelt hätte
größe und masse des neunzehnten hatten
ja bereits mike born und konzentriert
ermittelt mit diesen daten und den
informationen der bekannten planeten
fütterten sie den rechner
das ergebnis planet 9 hat einen
durchmesser von 46.000 60 kilometern und
ist damit vier mal so groß wie er der
streit auch energie im infrarotbereich
ab allerdings ist nur sehr schwach die
forscherin forscher ermittelten eine
temperatur von 27 grad kelvin ag - 226
grad celsius 37 grad wärmer als die
umgebung dort im weltraum genau hier
liegt die wichtigste erkenntnis dieser
forschung zu suchen ist der planet im
infraroten bereich bei einer wellenlänge
von 62 mikrometern
damit ist klar mit welchen instrumenten
nach planeten gesucht werden muss
allerdings gibt es einen haken unter
ungünstigen bedingungen kann kein
teleskop das der menschheit zur
verfügung steht den neunten planeten
aufspüren er ist einfach zu dunkel bzw
zu kalt er strahlt zu wenig energie ab
um aufgespritzt werden wenn er sich am
fernsten punkt befindet setzt
rothwell komplett weiß ist nicht
empfindlich genug um planeten
aufzuspüren er zukünftige teleskope
werden wahrscheinlich in der lage sein
die infrarotstrahlung aufzuspüren die
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
jetzt zum beispiel auf das in bau
befinden
lausanne optik survey telescope in chile
ja und wenn es etwas neues zum neunten
planeten gibt dann erfahrt ihr es
natürlich hier mit als die ersten dafür
mir hier einfach ein abo aufs auge
drücken nicht vergessen mir einen auf
die glocke bewegen für den extrem
unwahrscheinlichen fall dass er noch
keinen krieg zum abonnent seit das habt
ihr verpackt die besten videos von
klicks um drauf klicken und genießen
ansonsten bislang blatter